I thought I thought it would be
obviously so obviously you want me dead
you work for it it's gotta be Nic Cage
where'd you get these from all right
you'll be seeing a lot of changes around
here
Papa's got a brand new bag well I mean
that's right out of some of the songs in
the seventies I'm gonna go with Luke
Cage on that one yes I I know should
watch that movie all right
you're a hard-drinking short fuse mess
of a woman but sure not a piece-of-shit
house that's a gimme that's Luke Cage I
have an acronym for myself know what it
is BA D be a deep balls attitude
direction you should give yourself an
acronym it helps you visualize your
goals seem very badass at the same time
it seems a little visualize your goals
seems pretty heady I don't think Luke
would say it like that I don't go with
Nick Cage yes where's my money honey
okay I could be anybody I say that
sometime mmm Oh Luke 1s pay more money
I'm gonna go with Nick again Oh God
you're higher oh I'm gonna come back
let's go you want me out and put me out
Tin Man I'm going with
whoa look yes sweet Christmas move your
mouth or I'll remove your teeth I'm just
gonna go crazy and say Nick look again
uh what do you think I'm gonna do I'm
gonna save the day Luke in my
world can't curse back then those comic
books I'm going Nick yes being
superheroes we can't stay that's
it